I am here to introduce Lori. Ken Shot
Laurie introduces herself, uh, uh,
describes herself as an
intellectual Omnivore,
her undergrad degree from Swarthmore
or in biology and religion.
She got her masters from Harvard Divinity
School and Theological Studies and her
phd from Boston University
was an American studies.
I describe Lori as a personal friend as
well as an all around fascinating person.
She hosts lectures and discussions and
all sorts of topics including but not
limited to a politics,
economics, charitable giving,
religion and mass incarceration.
Uh,
the last two being related to our
positions as clerk of the first parish,
unitarian universalist of
Arlington and coordinator,
other mass incarceration working group.
Her diverse background gives her an
interesting and informed perspectives and
all of these topics today. She's here
to talk a bit about our third book,
gender inequality in our changing world.
And I'll hand you off to Laurie. Great.
Thank you very much.
I want to thank all of you for being here,
particularly Jonathan for inviting me
and Tim for handling the mechanics of
making the thing work. Um, and
so just a brief background,
gender inequality and our changing world
is a brand new textbook. Sociology.
I'm in a story and more or less as
we said intellectually on before, uh,
but I teamed up with a couple
of sociologists to write this.
And the reason we did this is because
this sociology of gender or textbooks that
are out there now tend to have been
written in the 1990s when there was this
really sort of triumphalist sort of idea,
that sort of view.
Then it states as the norm, you
know, everybody's headed our way,
Washington consensus,
and they had updated edition since then,
but the fundamental
conceptualization reflects that era.
And it seemed to us that we live in a
much more diverse and complicated world
than we did there.
The people thought they did in the 1990s.
And so we teamed up together to,
to try to focus on what's going on with
gender inequality in the contemporary
United States,
but really put it in a
richly international global
context and in an historical
context. So we're focusing on the theme
of change. How does things change?
How do things change? What is changing
with changing more quickly, with changing?
We're slowly all of this.
Um,
it's one of those huge topics that if
I'd realized what I was getting into,
I probably would've said no.
But in retrospect,
I'm glad I said yes and I'm very
grateful that you are all here today.
What I'm planning to do
is what I call a flyover.
It's a 450 page book
or something like that.
And I'm going to try to
talk about it in 30 minutes.
So there's no way I can
touch on everything in there,
but I'm just giving you a
flyover perspective of what's
in the book and some of
the things that I think people might find
interesting. Um, I'm going to ask that.
Well,
I'm going this quick speed through
people not comment or question during the
slides because several of these I
included in the book because they're so
interesting that if I were in a classroom,
I could use them to do 20 or 30 minutes
of conversation right there in the
classroom.
And that's not the goal for,
so it's a please do not be triggered by
the slides into conversation until the
end. And then there will
be time for Q. And. A.
I'm going to try to keep this very
hard to 30 minutes. Makes Sense.
So the first question is where
is gender inequality? Um,
and they're three different maps and I'm
going to show you that are looking at
gender inequality on a global scale.
Um,
this one is the United Nations has a
gender inequality index and any metric you
use,
any index you use has its problems.
Like this one makes Saudi Arabia look
sort of the same as the United States.
And that's because lots and lots of women
in Saudi Arabia go to a university and
get high education because they're
not allowed to do anything else.
There are brothers are allowed to go
work, go for play sports, be with friends,
go socialize, whatever. And all the young
women can do is go to the university.
So they go to university and that makes
the society looked like it has very good
to quality for women with you
measure it just by education.
So clearly we have some
problems with this index,
but there are some patterns
here that are real.
Um,
it is true that by many different metrics,
the United States has more gender
inequality than most wealthy democracies.
And the two things, the two places
that are changing most quickly,
our China over the last 60 years and
Latin America over the last 20 years and
Latin America is changing very quickly.
Also in terms of economic inequality.
It's the only religion of the world in
which economic inequality has decreased
over the last 20 years
rather than increased.
So there's interesting things going
on in both of those countries.
And in China that's very intentional
that the communist government,
when it came in,
said women hold up half the sky.
They said that girls had
to get primary education,
that employment had to open up to women.
And it takes a while for these
things to percolate through.
But China's changing very quickly as a
result, partly of intentional policies.
But that's not all that's going on.
So the next metric that I
would like to offer is, um,
this is gender gaps in life expectancies.
And what are the key distinctions
here that sociologists of gender,
Gender Studies, people use is between sex
and gender. Sex is what we're born with.
Whatever it is,
whatever complicated is,
it's what we're born with related to
reproductive anatomy and everything that
goes along with that.
Gender is what cultures make of that,
how cultures put meaning on that.
So six males are more
likely to die at every age.
That's includes prenatally. So you
know, this stuff, this is when,
when nobody knows until
recently, uh, um, what,
what sex they are.
So that has to do with sex.
Gender affects how that happens,
how quickly it happens to
the balance between them.
There are societies in which is not true.
There are societies in
which women die younger.
That's high level of gender inequality.
There are societies in which women live
much longer than men and that is awesome.
Excessively longer than men. And that
is also a form of gender inequality.
So the countries that are marked in red
are the countries where the gender gap
is too long, that men are
being disadvantaged by gender.
And that has a lot to do with violence,
has a lot to do with alcohol,
is a lot to do with risk taking behaviors.
Um,
and then the blue countries are where
women are likely dying of gender,
although in a few cases I think it's
because the gap is small because medical
care is really good.
It's not like Iceland up there is a
particularly bad country for women,
but that gives you another perspective on
the patterns here of gender inequality.
Here's another perspective on this.
Again,
if we have a natural sex
ratio and, and all, um,
all of this is a little difficult to tell
because what's natural because there's
no culture that doesn't have
culture, right? So we're,
we're sort of guessing
where the natural state is,
but the natural state seems to be that
about 1.05 boys are born for every girl,
of course, we really should say 105
boys for every hundred girls. But, um,
and there are a variety of
countries where that's not true.
So the India,
China,
some other smaller countries have many
more boys per girl than would be average
born would we natural born.
And that's because of sex,
selective abortion. And it,
um,
the notice that India and China together
and contain about a third of the
world's population.
So when you have those countries
selecting strongly for male births,
that means we have a real
disproportion in the population. Um,
the red countries are where
there's too few girls boys born.
And the reasons for that are
not completely understood,
but I believe that at least I'm sure
that at least part of the answer is that
when a woman is stressed during pregnancy,
male fetuses are more likely to miscarry
back to males are more likely to die at
every age. Males are more fragile.
So those countries are countries,
I believe in which women are so often
so stressed during pregnancy that their
sons in utero are more likely to die.
So gender inequality affecting both the,
the woman and the next generation.
So those three ways of thinking about
what's the big patterns here. Um,
there are four key causes of gender
inequality that we outline in the book.
And this is where the book
starts. Um, economics,
nearly all societies use gender to
allocate who does what work and to give.
And nearly all societies
give men preferential access
and control to economic
resources. The degree of that varies
a lot. How that works varies a lot,
but that seems to be very,
very common. Families,
nearly all societies assign the majority
of unpaid family care work to women,
childcare, eldercare cooking and cleaning
and just keeping everybody alive.
It seems to be women's
ultimate responsibility to
keep their families alive.
Control of sexuality,
patrialineal societies or societies where
family membership and inheritance are
trace through the man's lines,
through the father's line.
And the simple frame of that is you, you
get the name of your father's family. Um,
but in,
in patrialineal society,
there are many societies where only
sons inherit from their fathers. Um,
or only fathers can give,
can be quick to their sons and daughters,
but it's called to the fathers
maitre lineal societies.
You had trace inheritance
through your mother's line.
Now this results in very different types
of societies because obviously we all
know, given baby, we're
pretty sure who the mom is.
We're not necessarily sure who the
father is and societies that are patriots
lineal and consider patrialineal tracing
to be really important half to control
women's sexuality,
their reproductive capacity.
And that means basically all of their
behavior so that there can't be any doubts
about which baby is assigned to which man
and how stringently that's done varies
a lot. But there's a
fundamental difference between
patrialineal matria lineal
societies.
The vast majority of people have lived
in patrialineal societies and then
violence,
traditional societies worldwide wide
expect the male head of household,
the men who are in charge of the family
and therefore the society to maintain
discipline within the families.
And usually violence is
an acceptable method. Um,
and in addition, nearly everywhere, the
threat of sexual violence constraints,
women's lives in a variety of different
ways. A lot we could say about that.
So starting with economics,
the type of economic system that a
society has affects the degree of gender
inequality in. And it's not,
you know, tight correlation,
but sociology is always about
loose correlations here.
There's always going to be exceptions to
the rule. Hunting, gathering economies,
you share food.
You can't really own much in the way
anything else because you have to be able
to carry it with you.
There isn't much economic inequality to
be head horticultural economies which
use hose and other hand tools but don't
have big plows or domestic animals.
A big domestic animals tend to have
separate cultures for women and men,
they use gender to assign
the work roles very strongly,
but there tends to be a sort of
balance of power between them.
Agricultural and pastoral or hurting
economies tend to be the most unequal.
They tend to have what's called
family economies for the whole family.
Whatever that definition is,
works together to create everybody alive,
to create all the things that aren't
necessary and the men of the family are
given control of the
resources that are necessary.
Ownership of the land or the animals,
whatever their core resources and
also the right and therefore the
responsibility to control the family.
Labor force, I. E. The women and children.
So that's the most unequal type of society
in industrial economies to begin to
open up room for individuals
to earn their own incomes,
including for women to
earn their own incomes.
And that makes it possible for women to
have a degree of independence that it's
impossible in a family economy. Um, the,
this affects of obviously the women
who are earning their own incomes,
but it also fits women who aren't because
they have that possibility available
culturally,
economically.
And so industrialized societies
tend to increase gender equality,
increase the focus on the individual
as the unit of decision making,
knowledge based economies
like the one we're in,
especially here in this building.
Um, value, intelligence, expertise,
creativity,
social and relationship and emotional
skills and the ability to sit still and
focus and concentrate.
These are all skills that women tend
to have is at least as much as men.
And so in knowledge based economies
there tends to be increased in gender
equality,
although as we have seen,
nowhere has become gender
equal, um, in the United States.
Now, if you look at young
adults, age 25 to 29,
37% of the women and 30% of the
men have a bachelor's degree.
So we're really,
she seeing a shift there.
But if you control for education,
then men earn more than women
in every demographic group,
including young singles,
unmarried,
Yo don't have kids that the sort of most
free individuals still men earn more
than women if you correlate correct.
For Education.
Two key factors are important
for increasing increasing
gender equality within
families. So again, if we look worldwide,
one of them is women having access to
reproductive health care, contraception,
abortion, maternity care and
not having genital cutting,
particularly in fibrillation. Um,
women's lives. You know, it's,
it's just affects so many
things in a woman's life.
If she can control when she's going to
have children and if she has a really
good chance of surviving childbirth,
which in some societies CIC is
each time a woman gives birth,
she risks dying and her children
risk ending being motherless. Um,
the other key thing is if men bond with
their children and become engaged with
their infants,
they are much more likely to continue
to care for their children throughout
those children's lives. So this is
where we see the sex and gender thing.
You know, that, that it really
makes a difference when men,
um,
w w what seen sociologically is that
when men take paternity leave some amount
of time when they're infants or small,
that's long enough to bond with that
child that affects how they behave as
fathers for the rest of their lives.
So that requires paid paternity
leave or you know, uh,
generally paid paternity
leave to be available to have
this be really common and
policies that overcome social pressures.
So in most countries,
maybe all countries,
there's some degree of stigma
against men who prioritize childcare.
And the countries that have been most
successful in getting men to do this are
the ones that create maternity leave
first and then was called parental leave,
which can be taken by either parent,
but they require men to take some amount
of paternity leave dedicated for men
first. And then either parent can take
the parental leave and those societies are
seeing the stats.
I'm sure there's a limit to this,
but for each month of paternity leave,
a man takes his,
the mother of his children,
not always his wife, um,
has a 7% increase in earnings in the
future. So this really significant.
Um,
one note here is that women tend to United
States and other advanced countries,
economically advanced countries still
are having huge what's called motherhood
penalties. That when a,
when a woman is a mother,
she earns less than,
it's less likely to get hired or
promoted really for the rest of her life.
Even if you control for
experience, it's not just, Oh,
she took some time out of the workforce.
She's a little behind in you're
accumulating education and experience.
Even if you control for that,
women still earn less if they are mothers.
Men On the other hand,
more earn war if they are fathers.
And it's not just because
they tend to work more,
which some men do when they
have kids, they say, okay,
I really need to focus on this.
Even if you control for that,
men tend to earn more if they are fathers
get this fatherhood bonus as long as
they do not. Or there
are two criteria. One,
if a man spends significant time
taking care of his own children,
then he doesn't get the fatherhood bonus.
Like if he takes that paternity to leave,
probably won't get it.
And if he has brown skin, you have to be
white to get the the, the daddy bonus. Um,
which is related to but not the same
as African American men are much more
likely than a white American men to be
equal or close to equal partners around
taking care of small children.
So there's a lot of different
factors going on here. Okay.
This is one of my favorite charts.
This is about control of sexuality,
but using it from a small
statistical point of view,
if you look at the percent of people
in a society saying that their society
should accept homosexuality,
there's a strong correlation
with the per capita GDP.
That's a $70,000 there. Zero
down there. And as you can see,
there's a pretty strong correlation,
but there's also a lot of diversity.
And that diversity I
would argue is cultural.
So there are countries are whole regions
that are much more likely to accept
homosexuality than others and then
it then predicted by their GDP.
So these sort of purple dots up there,
those are European countries and
they tend to be relatively embracing.
These aren't green dots.
Here are Latin American countries which
are poor but also more embracing for
their GDP.
These red countries down here,
Subsaharan Africa don't be born
there. Um, if you were gay, um,
and then these are, um, Muslim
majority countries, those orange dots.
This is the United States,
which is pretty tolerant but not nearly
as much as you would think based on its
GDP. Statistically. Uh, and the
reason this is so important,
it's not just because of what it
means for gay folk in these societies,
but also because what tolerance of
homosexuality means is a belief that
sexuality belongs to the individual.
That in this traditional family
based patrialineal systems,
sexuality belongs to the family.
It is part of reproducing,
reproducing the family.
It is part of creating that labor force.
Women's bodies are very tightly controlled
so that the family has its official
integrity, often described
as purity, um, kept intact.
The more a society sees
sexuality as an individual thing,
something about individual choice,
something about individual prep
preference and pleasure and relationship.
But a matter of individual
choice, the more people go, hey,
it's a matter of individual choice. You
can choose who you're going to be with.
Um,
so this is a metric for that.
How much is Heidi has moved from seeing
sexuality as a property of the family to
seeing sexuality as a property
of the individual. Um,
so it's a very important graph
from that point of view. And again,
this is what I mean by Latin American
countries are changing quickly.
Um, violence. Some key things
to know about violence.
Men commit the vast majority of violence,
both that what's socially
approved and what's not.
And that's about maintaining social order.
It's about defending the community.
There's some evidence that may be the
classic Vikings were an exception to that,
that women fought equally.
But in the modern world that don't
seem to be any exceptions. Um, and,
and very few historically,
um,
men are also much more
likely to die violently. Um,
in 2008, uh, they were about three
times as likely as women. And that's,
that's common. Yeah. The men
worldwide, this is worldwide.
Statistics obviously are roughly
give or take a year by year,
three times as likely as
women to die violently.
But violence against girls and women
lie behind many of those other forms of
inequality.
That's how you enforce family discipline.
That's how you exclude women from the
workplace and from the street. You know,
that that's how a lot of
these things happen. Um,
key point violence is not
inevitable. It's not just, Oh,
men are going to be violent.
This is back to the sex gender thing.
Because levels of violence vary
enormously between different societies and
within one society they
can change quite quickly.
They can also change over the generations.
Those Vikings,
those warlike notorious Vikings,
are the ancestors of the modern peaceable
Scandinavians. It's the same gene pool.
So it's not about the jeans.
Um,
and then as of 2011,
violence had decreased,
whether it looks at decades,
centuries or millennia.
And here I highly recommend
Steven Pinker's better
angels of our natures. Why,
why violence has declined. The
book draws a lot on that. Um,
I can do only a little bit with it,
but it's a great book.
And he documented this and then talked
about a variety of reasons why that's
true. What's going on in Syria has
caused an increase in violent deaths.
Um,
but it's too soon to tell whether that's
sort of a blip in the grand historical
chart or whether it means
some sort of trend. It, it's,
so this is not as true over the decades
now as it was, but you may be going back.
I hope so. Um, so this is drawing
again from Steven Pinker's work.
When government is not trusted to provide
security and justice people have what
he calls it. I call self
hope, self-help justice.
Where in my society, if somebody
robs my house, I called the police,
I say help somebody robbed my house
and they hopefully find who did it.
And you know, they take care of it.
Whereas in a traditional society,
if somebody steals something from you,
there's no police to call on, right?
There's no government to call on.
So you have to be willing to exact
retribution more to the point.
You need to have a reputation to exact
retribution so that they won't steal from
you in the first place and they won't
beat you up in the first place and they
won't kill you in the first place
so that it's a family level fit.
And that's called honor,
that having that reputation for being
quick to respond to insult is essential
for preservation of groups in societies
where there is no government that can
provide protection to families.
So you get this culture of male honor,
which gets intertwined with his idea of
female purity, the patrialineal society,
family, all of that. In such
societies, girls have little schooling,
women are economically dependent
on their men and their families.
There's high levels of violence within
the families as well as between families,
high death rates, high birth
rates, those need to go together,
high levels of poverty, high risk
of political violence. And war,
all of which reinforces
ineffective government.
There's a spiral going on here.
When girls get educated, things change.
That seems to be one of those levers. Um,
so women are able to contribute more
economically if they're more educated.
Families become more economically stable
because there's more people able to do
more diverse things. Child mortality
decreases really quickly. Giving women,
giving girls a primary education really
affects the survival rates of their
children. Um, birth rates decreased
because families like, Oh, you know,
hopefully my kids will survive so I can
have fewer of them and women have more
choice in whether to have children.
So the next education,
the next generation is better educated.
It's healthier, it lives longer,
and the population size stabilizes.
Women have more say in their families and
communities and one of the things they
do is use those families and those that,
those families and communities to create
structures that help them keep their
kids alive. It seems to be
one of those universal things.
If you give women political power,
one of the things,
the first thing is they go for
is clean water supplies. Um,
and governments provide
more public services.
It's a little more complicated what
women do in countries like ours in the
United States, but in countries
where you're just on the edge,
women really like clean water.
Um, so public poverty goes down,
public health improves violence,
decreases chances of war,
decreases another spiral.
But going a different direction.
Say here's how to encourage girls
schooling in poor countries.
And there's a lot of different
parts of this. You need schools,
but you also need the, the teachers
and books and Internet access.
Your quality is really important.
There's a lot of places in this world
where people can go to school for several
years and still not really
become literate or numerate.
And when parents see that their
girls are not getting educated,
they're much more likely take the girls
out of school because girls Labor's
always needed at home,
always need it and families and the
girl isn't benefiting for the schooling.
Girls are more likely to be withdrawn.
Um,
of course it's good for boys too that
they actually learned something in school.
Um, make girls safe on
the streets and in school.
The violence thing provides safe
bathrooms and sanitary supplies.
There are parts of the world,
like Pakistan,
a third of the schools have no
bathrooms and no running water.
And when girls go off into the fields
or whatever to relieve themselves
privately, they are more likely to get
assaulted. This is particularly a problem.
What's girls start menstruating?
Uh, there are places where, um,
pilot studies have just given out
menstrual pads and girls attendance.
Adolescent girls are much more likely
to go to high school if they have
something,
they can be private with
conditional cash transfers.
These are huge in particularly
Brazil and Mexico are best known,
but there's lots of countries around the
world that are giving cash transfers to
mother's much more than fathers, um,
because they use the money differently.
But to poor families if
they meet certain criteria.
And typically that includes sending
their kids to school and getting basic
medical care including immunizations.
And that really increases both
education and the wellbeing of the next
generation. Um, but unconditional
cash transfers can work too.
There's been pilots studies
done and think it's in Morocco,
in Malawi where you just give families
a little bit of cash, not very much,
and they're much more likely to send
their daughters to school because they're
pulled away from that edge of survival.
And many families want their
daughters to go to school.
They just can't afford it. Um,
reproductive healthcare again,
um,
you know,
mothers being in good shape needs their
daughters are more likely to go to
school and focus on disadvantaged
groups that nowadays,
if you look at primary education
and you look at the dominant group,
I think it's every country
or nearly every country,
maybe every country there's gender
parity at the primary level.
The place that we really hurt around
gender parity on the primary level is in
marginalized groups within
countries. Usually ethnic
groups could also be a cast.
That's where you see gender
inequality within the country.
So at primary level it gets
more complicated after that.
So those are two key things to keep in
mind when we're talking globally focusing
on United States,
there's two things I want you to know.
Gender inequality decreased,
decreased by many different
ways between 1970 and 2000.
And since then it has leveled out. We see
this map over and over and over again.
And then educational levels,
how much education people have,
which sociologists use as a proxy for
social class as a much larger impact on
life patterns now than it
did in 1970 or before, um,
or 1980 or before. So
here's one of my graphs, um,
that shows this.
So this red line is the frequency of
rape in victim studies where researchers
get on the phone and they call households
randomly selected around the country
and they say, what crime have you
experienced in the last six months?
And the totally this.
And so if that,
that beginning spot is
1973 of normalized to 100.
And as you see,
the incidence of rate has gone
down by roughly three quarters,
80% since 1973.
Big Change,
but it has more or less
leveled out since 2000. Um,
the dotted line of there is the
incidence of rape as reported to police.
Most rapes are not reported,
but their police reports went up and up
and up during this time period when the
rate was actually going down because of
the work to de de de de stigmatize rape,
the women became more likely to
report it men too, but mostly women.
And then since around 1995,
the reports have gone down at roughly
the same incidents as the, um,
what's being done by victim studies.
And then this blue line is the murder
rate during this time period, again,
by the same normalization.
And as you see,
the murder rate has gone
down by roughly 50%,
and there's lots that violence in
general is gone down. Lots of discussion.
Nobody's really no consensus
about why that's true,
but the difference between that
and that I would argue as gender,
that there is an increasing understanding
that gender equality is good,
that women should be able to
say no, you know, uh, that,
that coercion is not a
desirable part of masculinity.
These are all changes that are happening
with gender and that's making that
difference, which is a
significant difference. Um,
another graph, this is the divorce rate
per thousand people starting in 1870.
This spike is right after World War II.
Lots of people married
in hasting came apart.
This spike is often called
the feminist movement,
but I would say it's more broadly all
the changes of the 1960s which were huge
and couples didn't always change at the
same pace and became much more likely to
come apart.
But as you see,
the divorce rate has been coming
down pretty steeply since then.
Still high historically speaking. But
that, that's a trend line down, you know.
Um, but if we look more closely
at different economic groups,
it's all among college graduates.
So these three lines are for people
who are not college graduates and they
started in the 70s and this is when
they got married and their chance of
divorcing within 10 years.
So those who got married in the 70s had
a significantly more higher chance of
divorce is they were not
college graduates but, but the,
the difference is much
more now than it was then.
And that is the pattern that comes
up in one cluster of statistics after
another. Um, here,
this is life expectancies among
Americans since 1900 and as,
um, the, the um,
blue lines are for black folk and white
lines are for white folk and the solid
lines are for women and the
dotted lines are for men.
And that will be true in all
graphs of this sort of. Um,
and as you can see in 1900,
the race was the really
big determining thing.
We had this small gender gap,
which indicates high gender inequality
and race really affected life expectancy
as a century has gone on.
That's somewhat reversed over here.
Ray still has an impact.
Gender has an impact. Um,
the gender gap for blacks is significantly
higher than the gender gap for whites,
but gender and race are more
coequal than they were. Um,
if we look more narrowly to now to
education, it's really different.
This is for Americans with,
with no high school diploma
just since 1990 to 2008.
And this is the line for white men
and that's the line for white women.
And as you can see,
life expectancies for white Americans
without a high school diploma had been
going down there.
Now basically it's the same as life
expectancies for black Americans without a
high school diploma.
And there's a lot of things that are
correlated that since I sent in these
slides,
there was a New York Times article
talking about a recent study talking about
levels of suicide and deaths
related to substance addiction,
both alcohol and illegal drugs.
There's a lot of despair going on among
less educated people and that's related
to all of this. Um, so the
gap for education is huge.
White men with a college degree live 13
years longer than white men without a
high school diploma for White Women.
The gap is only 10 and a half years,
but that's, that's a
decade, you know. Um, here,
uh, this is one of those things we
could look at a lot, but we want,
this is looking at full time earnings
meeting weekly earnings by gender and
education.
Since 1980 men's earnings
average decreased unless
they had a bachelor's degree
that these men up there with a bachelor's
degree went up by a quarter in terms
of their average earnings,
women's earnings increased unless they
did not have a high school diploma.
So the general trajectory for women
and the general trajectory for men,
it's really different here man could
pretty much count on earning more than
women in their social world.
Now, not as much likely,
but not as much labor force
participation rates have really changed.
Men had been going down since the 1950s.
Women obviously went up,
but then women have also been
teetering down since around 2000. Um,
some of the reasons for men's decreasing
participation rate are really good.
Yeah.
When men are staying in school longer,
they're taking time off to
take care of kids or travel.
They are retiring that in the 1950s,
the typical man died before the
retirement age. Now the tickle,
but typical man lives past retirement age,
big difference affects the labor force
participation rate. This is good. Um, but,
and they're often in reasonably good
health if they are well educated,
less educated women.
Men However,
suffer from very high
levels of unemployment under
employment and incarceration
and they often retire or
leave the workforce because
they are in ill ill health
rather than because they're ready
to move on to something else.
So it's a very different demographic.
Here's another,
if you look at percent of
births to unmarried women,
which is getting a lot of
conversation these years, um,
if you look at groups of women who did
not go to college or had some college,
they're real racial differences. But if
you look at women with a college degree,
those racial discipline differences
disappear. Um, at this point,
black and Hispanic women have the same,
basically the same birth rate,
whether or not they are married for,
for white women, there's a difference.
But again, among college graduates,
the differences disappear.
Here's looking at those who
have never married by age 40.
And as you can see, there's huge
differences based on race, gender,
and education for black men.
Without a high school diploma, it's,
well less than half will ever marry by
age 40, which probably means ever. Um,
two thirds of Americans say that a man
has to be able to support a family before
he gets married. One third of
Americans think the same of for women.
So that's part of what drives
this gender difference.
Obviously lots more
that can be said there,
but this is a graph of the
ages of people when they marry.
And as you can see back at the turn of
the 20th century, it, it was really,
um, uh, the, that, um,
gender affected this a lot and now race
affects it more that there's been a
shift in what, what drives this,
what fundamentally drives this,
and this is again related to these ideas
about financial stability that nowadays
most people feel, and this
is all ages, all genders,
all race and economic groups,
educational groups feel that they need
to get some sense of financial stability
before they get married. They need
to get themselves professionally.
That was what the college
graduates call it. Just,
just some financial stability for folks
who don't have a professional aspiration.
Um, and communities where many men
never achieve financial stability.
They don't get married.
They,
but most people want to have children
in their twenties when it really works
well to have children. So
a lot of people are, are,
and women in their
twenties are often saying,
I can handle raising a kid or two
and most of them have a kid or two,
not lots. Um, but I can't take on being
financially responsible for a man as well.
So we have huge patterns going on here.
Um,
so that gives you a flavor.
What I mean when I say that education is
really affecting our country more than
it was, whereas gender inequality
headed is my final question.
There are sort of different possible
answers to this and I don't,
I'm not coming down on anyone's side,
but one theory is that gender equality,
we will continue to
increase in United States.
So we have a lot of positive feedback
loops that are just going to keep going.
A knowledge based economy.
Two thirds of women in nearly half of
men say they believe in the social,
economic and political
equality of the sexes. Ref.
Roughly half of those people
describe themselves as feminists.
The other half don't.
But you know, that's the,
they still believe in equality
of the genders. So you know, um,
laws not always followed,
but laws prohibit gender discrimination
and they allow it in force.
Say that women have a right to refuse sex
and use contraception at least so far.
Um,
and social tolerance of violence,
particularly sexual violence is
decreasing, has decreased in,
seems to be continued to decrease.
So all of those factors suggest that
gender equality will continue to increase
globally. Nearly all big international
institutions, governments,
not all governments.
Many governments have realized that
increasing gender equality and women's
empowerment seems to be key to creating
stable societies with prosperity,
with economic stability, good
economies, lack of violence.
All of this seems to be intertwined.
You know,
I'm not saying anything radically new
here. We'll bank will say it too. Um,
and many poor and middle income countries
have started a positive cycle of
growth, more education, more women's
employment, increasing health,
women's empowerment, these things, again,
positive feedback cycles
going in a good direction.
There are theories, however, the
gender equality will stagnate.
As I said in the u s metrics
have stagnated since around
2000 women still have
primary responsibility for
unpaid family work everywhere.
Even in the most egalitarian countries
like Sweden, the Nordic countries,
they're working on it,
but it's still really women's ultimate
responsibility for their families and for
less lucky and prosperous countries.
Um,
ethnic groups that are marginalized or
stigmatized or live in war zones often
have really high levels of gender
inequality along with all the other things
they are suffering.
And it's really hard to break those
cycles for a stigmatized or violence prone
areas. Um, so theories
that gender equality,
inequality,
inequality will increase.
Societies tend to become more stagnant
and more intolerant and more full of
resentment when economic situation
is either level or falling.
When people have a falling
standard of living,
they often finds feely they'd
need to find someone to blame.
And this can intersect with masculinity,
that if a man feels like
it's his responsibility to
be a breadwinner and to be
therefore in control of his
family and he can't do that,
men can become very resentful.
And some men try to shore up their
sense of masculinity by exercising it in
other ways. I eat dominating
women and dominating children. Um,
so that is a pattern that has been
seen in many different contexts.
If the United States is headed into a
period of economic decline or some people
in the United States are headed into
a long period of economic decline,
if this pattern has its obvious risks,
um,
and another way plug countries as well,
not just the United States.
And then women tend to suffer more from
men than men from political and economic
instability from social disorder and
war. Children's suffer the most, right?
Because they're the most vulnerable.
But the more a woman has to
work to keep her family alive,
just to subsist subsisting the lesson
or she has, she has for anything else.
Um, and climate change and
environmental stresses,
economic stresses look
like they are increasing.
The Pentagon has put out
research suggesting that
there's going to be increasing
economic instability, political
instability and military
instability worldwide.
So they are preparing for that.
Again,
I don't know if that's
what's going to happen,
but it's certainly is a possibility
that environmental stresses will lead to
more social stresses,
will lead to more gender inequality
in countries where those cycles,
uh,
can actually reverse.
So thank you very much for the city.
Questions,
comments?
Um,
so the part where women are going at
graduating college now more than men,
how does that track by class and race?
Ah, it's more true for, um,
families that were, the parents did not
go to college. So in elite families,
it's very likely to sit down at all of
the children will go to college no matter
what. The small exceptions, not, but,
but families where some people go
to college and some people not.
That's where you really see
the differences that the
girls are more likely to go.
And one of the reasons for
that it is believed is that,
um,
is gender discrimination in the workforce.
That at any given level of education,
the boy or young man
is more likely to get,
get a job and a better paid job
than the woman at that level.
So women have to get more education
or in order to get economic equality.
And then on top of that,
women see themselves as having
primary responsibility for children.
So they really want to get
economic stability. So there's,
there's gender issues
driving the motivations in
families that are less elite,
less privileged.
Uh,
when you talked about factors that affect
a family's decision about whether to
support their daughters going to school,
you mostly talked about factors
that were internal to the family,
the economic situation or the
attitudes towards the girls' education.
Uh, one of the things that's been
surprising from watching the world news,
at least for me over the last decade,
is the growth of the belief
of a political cultural.
That I have the right to tell other
families not to send their daughters to
school, but that's seen as, um,
a major political plank of a group
like Boko Haram or in Pakistan.
And I was curious whether you see that
as being the outgrowth of economic
factors or is this something that also
could play into unfortunately one of
those last three slides?
Oh, absolutely. Um, the real answer is
very complicated as you can imagine. Um,
and I glossed over it,
but that safety issue that a lot
of how the Taliban, Boko Haram,
other extremist groups have deterred
parents from sending their kids to school,
particularly their daughters is by making
schools seem threatening that, that,
that there may be violence there, there
isn't violence all the time, obviously,
but if you were scared that your
kid is going to get attacked, raped,
killed for going to school,
you're more or less likely to get,
send them to school. Um,
and I see the, um, yeah,
Boko Haram literally means
Western knowledge or Western
education is forbidden
or is taboo.
And I see those movements is very much
part of a reaction against Western
ideology, Western
colonization. Um, and, uh,
I'm not justifying it,
but, but saying yes,
there's a global debate that's going on
now and one of the places it's playing
out is on this dispute on who should
have control over people's bodies,
particularly girls and women's bodies.
Should it be the family and community
as it was in traditional societies or
should it be the individual?
Most of the world sees the United States
and Europe is saying individuals should
have control over their bodies, over
their destinies, over how they dressed,
how they behave,
and the men of Boko Haram and the tempo
and the Taliban see that as a real
threat to them as men,
but also to their whole traditional
society that's based on the group defining
what individuals will do.
So gender is one of the places that
this fundamental argument over who,
where the locus of control
should be is playing out.
Does that help?
So how do you imagine the impact of
the birth gender sex inequality in 15,
20 years in China and India and Africa?
Um,
now that those kids that
are maturing into adults,
but the gender equality's all off.
Thank you for asking. That is,
it's not just in the future.
It's happening now because this had
been going on as long as people have had
access to ultrasounds and
that that's young adults now.
And so particularly in China,
India, Vietnam, a few other places,
you have really big disparities
and there's real concerns about the
militarization that happens when a society
has too many uh, men that they need.
Young men,
young men who can't settle into a
family are often pretty hard to control.
Um,
and so and,
and particularly in societies
where the sense of membership,
the sense of belonging is
still very strongly rooted
in families that, you know,
the China, as I said, it's
changing very quickly.
And that was partly because
of the ideological changes
as partly because of the
economic changes driven by industries,
industrialization.
But it isn't like a society
changes instantaneously overnight.
And so young men in China now know
that they have really hard odds around
getting married. The only ones are going
to, but the lesson lean ones or not.
Same thing in India where one of the
things we talk about in the book is issues
of rape and we focus on
Indiana in the United States,
but there are a lot of young men in India,
lower status,
young men who know that they're never
going to be able to afford to marry.
And in a society where marriage is
how you get your value out of life,
that can be devastating. So yes, this is
already rippling through these societies.
The key thing that I,
I'm going to take the opportunity to add
is that South Korea used to be in this
camp and it is among adults.
It's still is, you know that.
But if you go back and look
at the graph now, Jen, it's,
there's some sex selective
abortion going on in South Korea,
but not nearly as much.
Not enough to show up on the map.
And the reason for that it seems is partly
ideological preaching about, you know,
gender equality and all of that.
But even more the country put in a
strong public pension service for older
adults because in traditional societies,
when you get old,
you need to rely on your
children to keep you alive.
And in traditional societies where only
males can have access to good jobs and
ownership of property,
that means you need to have sons
or you're going to be destitute.
And South Korea got access to ultrasounds
and good simple abortion technology at
a stage where parents still
depended on their sons to survive.
Industrialized societies, people
tend to want to have one, two,
maybe three children, sometimes
zero. And so they were using sex,
selective abortion to make sure
they'd be secure in their old age.
Once the country started putting in
secure what equivalent to social security,
the use of sex, selective abortion
went down a lot. That works.
Making it illegal. It doesn't work. It's
illegal in China, it's illegal in India,
it's happening. Um, so that's the key
thing there. And yes, all of this,
those societies are consciously
and intentionally struggling
with these problems.
Do you think that would lead
to war, gender, and inequality,
or to greater valuation of women?
It can lead to a greater valuation of
women as sexual and reproductive partners,
which tends to lead to more gender
inequality in the broader political and
economic realm.
China has had an increase in what's
called wife theft or wife capture,
where you grab a woman and go marry her,
uh,
whether or not she was already married,
um,
that that's an extreme
form of gender inequality.
Whether or not she has
consents, obviously, you know,
if it's fun by physical capture and
that's not happening everywhere,
but that is one of the patterns that's
emblematic of what happens when there's a
real gender imbalance that women get
valued as sexual and reproductive objects.